you're welcome to this video playing a
one from the UK the French the French
the French let's see a play I usually
play 9293 I can try for a change maybe
try this line with with c3 and f4 it is
very dangerous for white to white them
for what himself because you you're very
vulnerable with the slow development but
it's level that's interesting because
you gain so much space you're basically
on the first black to play in a very
very sharp and direct way to get counter
play if you play play this very slowly
as black then white will enjoy a big big
supported center the key point our other
piece sacrifices like an sometimes
sacrifice pieces on e5 or deform check
yeah usually there's King f2 as a
response but I wonder about perfect d
tubes are some really bad I can take you
five and play castles ok but i'll wait i
go here then he can already take it five
so i must do that yeah i mentioned
before it can be very dangerous for
Wyatt mm-hmm this this kind of setup
hmm yeah maybe something already went
wrong here but take only five feet just
castles and I don't really know what to
what to reply I take with the depot I'm
in you can just play Bishop c5
threatening mate and this looks
completely completely idiotic but what
else if I take with the pawn short
castles yeah Bishop g2 now that looks
terrible Bishop g2 we can even consider
too yeah the piece sex are working 95 is
a possibility night if i fel yeah yeah
95 95 account even take because of the
mate so probably need to go here and now
that's 93 also threatened oh wow 95 am
immediately mated so night f for maybe
half the squeem III
two
yeah what else Queenie 3 and 0 besides
other ideas I mean even rook takes f-4s
possibility okay yeah I must I must do
that is this so great okay can play just
g5 at the end just 25 okay so if i take
with the [ __ ] with the night g5 maybe I
can
tween age 5 or Queenie one I can't play
Queen you on takes takes the night is
hanging it's it's it's probably a losing
anyway but then there's also the move b6
which can be good okay 21 I can just
take a plane I g6 it go with it will win
back the peace
Queen age five some takes and there's
nothing
I can take I can just take it
it's a check if this is the problem to
check
hmm
check
yeah there's no more freedom I could
also just resign yeah it was just this
is not playable and this and then the
way I approach this seems completely
unplayable yeah come on white resigned
so this is a real opening disaster I
don't know I don't know how to how this
is played maybe this this is all this is
bad already I don't know Oh a three so
that you prevent the bishop I mean it's
I know this is a playable line now f4 I
mean this earth has been played by a
barn on to me he knows what he's doing
but I don't really know how to exactly
play or h4 here check what's clear is
that this is already already tricky
maybe I need to I need to go king of two
empathic can I cannot clicking of two
here check you can just just take it so
Bishop d2 takes yeah maybe I really need
to play details in five the computer
already gives gives us as lost for
watching them I must have I'm not not
quite sure where exactly the mistake was
this you cannot defend anymore check
this losers in various ways maybe it's
really a 3 and something make sure that
there's not Bishop before coming yeah as
I mentioned this is a very risky line
like if everything went goes nicely from
white and black is really a suffering
from this lack of space but white has
some especially weekend is king a lot
and he played this nice leap just
just getting a quick win or okay thanks
for watching